if you open an iPhone this is what you'd
see all these parts were put together by
a company called Foxconn any of the
parts themselves and manufactured by
Foxconn almost any piece of electronics
has at least some components from the
company which is owned by this guy
billionaire Terry quark he found success
by making massive deals with the world's
biggest tech companies and being able to
follow through
he's always put high and delivery number
one even at times if that means taking a
loss or taking big risks on buying
equipment or setting up facilities
because he's confident that once he
lands that order they're gonna be stuck
with him and it's usually the case he's
even expanded operations into the u.s.
by building a 14.5 billion-dollar
factory in Wisconsin this is how one man
turned a small operation in a shed into
the biggest electronics operation on the
planet Foxconn is one of the largest
employers in the world with over 1
million workers during peak iPhone
season and that's a commodity
politicians like to offer during
election time jobs so when it came time
for president Donald Trump and various
US states to decide where they wanted
the promised factory GWAR had them
playing against each other for the best
offer and Wisconsin took the bait and
and offered a lot I offered massive
massive incentives to to get [ __ ] Khan
they're really one of the largest
incentive packages in US history
critics say the factory will most likely
not create as many jobs as promised and
people are calling it a white elephant
but Gua doesn't care
Wisconsin is paying him four point five
billion dollars in taxpayers money or
$1,800 per taxpayer we've got a Green
Bay Packers Jersey with your name on it
at the end of the day Terry war is a big
winner and it's yet to be seen whether
Wisconsin will be a winner
other countries have sought similar
deals including Brazil Indonesia and
even various Chinese provinces and
that's because guar has a reputation for
being able to pull off massive
operations offering companies a one-stop
shop for electronics there's no other
company in the world that can do what
Terry Boyd does even two decades later
Foxconn is still the master of assembly
and it's because Terry Gore is always
looking to try and you know look ahead
and try and keep customers happy
early on guar saw opportunity by
streamlining processes via automation
and cutting out the middlemen in the
1970s Taiwan had a booming export
economy but most electronics from that
time were made in Japan where the
factories were and then traded in Taiwan
who had the connections to the Western
world a 23 year old gua worked as a
shipping clerk and got a first-hand view
of the potential to make money and he
realized well you know there's money in
this maybe I should go out on my own and
do some of this why be the person in the
middle when I can be the one doing the
actual original production he decided to
go into business for himself using a
seven and a half thousand dollar loan
from his mother he rented a shed in a
gritty taipei suburb called to chunk
bought a couple of plastic molding
machines and started making channel
changing knobs for black-and-white
televisions after that he had a series
of big breaks starting with making
components for Atari and later Dell at
that time Dell and other PC companies
would buy parts from their suppliers and
assemble them in their own factories but
guar created a production line
integrating most of these parts and
processes from the raw steel for PC
casings and electrical connectors to the
final assembly guar was also among the
first wave of Taiwanese to set up
factories in mainland China he saw the
writing on the wall in the 70s that this
was a place to do business to to build
things to manufacture things not only at
a low labor rate but there was just
going to be
to fool our staff all these years later
40 years later it's almost the most
perfect government our corporate
partnerships in history
eventually guar landed a deal with Apple
and the rest is history over 50% of
their estimated one hundred and sixty
five billion dollars in revenue now
comes from Apple but it wasn't always
going smoothly
Foxconn hit international headlines in
2010 after a series of workers suicides
at their main Factory in Shenzhen take
all the Qin and put it in context of a
suicide rating in Chinese is around 20
per hundred thousand teri war had about
a million people working for him at the
top of the annual cycle so that would
imply 200 suicides yeah but they had you
know 14-hour well below average but
certainly higher than anyone expected
and because this was a company supplying
the Apple it became famous very very
quickly as the Apple supplier and the
suicide problem after the 2010 scandals
he raised wages set up healthcare
clinics and even set up hotlines to give
advice to help workers Foxconn weather
the crisis but it was already facing a
bigger long-term issue for the past
decade revenue for electronic hardware
manufacturing has decreased and software
is on the up almost all the world's
biggest tech companies are now non
Hardware GWAR who is a manufacturer at
heart hasn't been able to diversify
products Foxconn has been trying and
trying and trying the years to get into
things like cloud services software but
they're just not very good at it Terry
Ward doesn't have that creative thinking
he doesn't look at a product and say how
can I add value and charge more for it
and that's the biggest challenge facing
Foxconn into the future
you